servus aus dortmund ich bin euer sydney
herzlich willkommen zur neuen folge auto
bild das magazin wir testen wir euch die
neuesten die coolsten die teuersten und
die günstigsten autos ich weiß gar nicht
wo ich aufhören soll was ich aber sagen
kann ist heute haben wir eine mega
sendung für euch
mit den wohl wichtigsten ford im auto
bild chef der ford lightning heavy metal
aus detroit hat er das zeug hier
verbrenner das wasser zu reichen da wo
früher sechs oder acht zylinder motoren
waren gibt es jetzt
400 liter stauraum größte frank den es
bislang bei einem elektroauto gegeben
hat und angriff auf den golf was kann
der opel astra sports tourer gut und
weniger gut das ist für ein ganz ganz
großer schrift das ist schon nicht mehr
massenhersteller und wir testen das
kanzler mobil von olaf scholz für eine
halbe million euro hier darf man
wenigstens ein bisschen die sau
rauslassen und das machen wir jetzt auch
mal
[Musik]